thanks to curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video to see extended
content from this video check out my
channel on nebula
oh no oh no
what do you mean i know
don't say things like that lots of
people follow this youtube channel
because of the vlogs i made during my
phd in atmospheric physics at the
university of exeter unfortunately
however i had to graduate at some point
and that necessarily meant the end of my
videos showing what doing a phd was like
however there are lots of people out
there doing interesting phd projects and
so in this video series i'm spending a
few days with a new researcher each
episode showing you what that life is
like learning a bit about them and
learning about the topic of their thesis
this week i'm at the university of
cambridge a minorly successful offshoot
of the university of oxford to chat to
sam a researcher who's part of my online
community about his phd i'm sam ryan and
i am a
second year psd student at the institute
of astronomy at cambridge and my phd is
in galactic archaeology now i was in
town to talk to sam but also to give a
talk at the university's physics society
which was quite an intimidating prospect
considering cambridge's reputation in
physics but more on that later for now
you're probably wondering what on earth
is galactic archaeology if you think of
normal archaeology where you have an
archaeologist sticking in the sand
looking for like a pothole pan or relics
of an old age that tells you about that
civilization it's now trying to think
about our galaxy the stars are our
relics we're using those the dynamics of
the stars so where they are in the sky
and the position of the velocity of the
stars and that can tell you basically
the potential of the
how the strength of gravity around the
milky way and that tells you lots about
dark matter um history of the milky way
so how it got bigger over time and then
from that like history of the universe
so we're very obviously wired up here
we've got we've got
we're attached by a microphone but
that's because this is an incredibly
echoey building yeah where is the what
is this place so this is the university
of cambridge's northumberland telescope
funded by the duke of northumberland
back in 18
all the time checks history behind him
yeah
1838 i can read the thing behind the
camera
and it was given to the university to
look after for by the royal astronomical
society it's really difficult to convey
even with the gopro just how kind of
immense it meant
like this is effectively just when you
think of a telescope it's yes it's this
is when you dream of telescope or being
an astronomer this is probably what
people thought or think it still is a
big tube
lights on one end and then this this
whole thing what we said before we
started filming was it's almost like a
reverse gun like a reverse artillery
piece because it's just this huge um
you know like a like a barrel of a gun
and then you as the astronomer lay down
here at the bottom like that's the
eyepiece down there
um with a little bed so i assume it's
just because of how awkward it would be
if you were looking at um styles
basically just right above you and so
this telescope probably i think was
mainly for like catalogues and stuff
that's basically what we could do with
astronomy back in the day was you would
lie there you'd have your book your big
almanac and you'll just be like writing
star double
somewhat bright at this position and you
read off some of the numbers on the
telescope and that would be where it is
obviously it was cutting edge when it
was built but it hasn't been for quite a
while
yeah more or less um probably a couple
hundred years possibly so when people
think of being an astronomer
now what should they be imagining
instead of this so we still do use
telescopes we have the very well named
the very large telescope
um
you know it's not overwhelmingly large
because that was too large and so we do
use telescopes they come in all shapes
and sizes from radio dishes for radio
waves and
um the really weird gamma-ray telescopes
but then the other group of astronomers
would use most likely use satellites
which is what i mainly use so if you're
not using this what instrument are you
using in your phd so i'm using
um satellite gaia so this is
my boy gaia this is a one to ten model
of the satellite itself
which is
at the lagrange point two and it's
basically spinning eight times a day
taking
an essence a video of
the sky and so it's mapping the whole
skies not just specific portion but
the whole 360. and so the way it does
that is much like the way we see and so
it's got these two
openings and in essence it's like our
eyes
and so light comes in
here hits a mirror and then sort of
reflects down and hits eventually a
main camera
and that camera is
in essence like a videotape it watches
the sky and then it's processed back on
earth and then from there they can pick
out individual stars and individual
objects so the way to imagine how
precise scarra is is that if you took a
human hair
i went all the way to australia sydney
and measured it from here in cambridge
that is the precision of gaia so you're
using
this piece obviously not this piece of
equipment you're using something that is
10 times bigger than this out in space
yeah
do you feel
how does that make you feel
like a
child with a big toy um
very complicated toy but
it's nice just be able to like visualize
that this is what i'm using and it
it's somewhat like it's just so
interesting i find that it's so
it's quite simple yeah like
there's not it doesn't like the inside
doesn't move there's nothing yet that's
spinning or
dry rotating or whatever it's only like
coming in bouncing off some stuff going
through some prisons refracting
and that's it but in essence it's like a
pair of human eyes because you've got
two things so you can do parallax right
yeah and that's just rotating three
times a day
you're just creating a movie that you
then pull all of this stuff out of
that's the impressive thing yeah to me
that's the amazing thing yeah
it really is and that it's not like the
lhc where they have they've spent
decades creating these massive
experiments and going through petabytes
data this is just a
very simple machine like the human body
just looking at the sky and spinning and
recording it as it does
but nobody knows about it because it's
it's not hubble yeah because it's not
hello because it's not on camera because
it's not gwst because it's not lhc
no one knows about it just just up there
quietly doing its job yeah
so to show you how the sausage is made a
little bit we we've just filmed the bit
with the gaia model and can you just
repeat what you just said to me about we
were shown before the model i didn't
catch it on camera but we had a guy who
gave us a run through the model and what
each bit meant just to kind of for my
benefit um who was that um his name is
um jerry gilmore and he is basically the
reason why the guy satellite exists
so we we got the intro from the
architect
of the whole
multi
100 million dollars i think it's just
under a billion
so i think the running cost is 900
million
so there we go
so my specific phd is i don't know um
literally i'm mainly focusing on
stuff called substructure so
substructure is any form
of material that is distinct from the
main body of the milky way
so
we have the disc in the milky way but
then we have like these ripples these
like peanuts and they look like peanuts
in space
and these are over densities and so my
phd is looking for these specific over
densities analyzing them and trying to
tell us trying to work out what that
tells us
about the the galaxy that deposited them
so
collided and mixed in yep just to
restate that in case you missed it our
galaxy the milky way was involved in a
galactic car crash a few billion years
ago the name of the galaxy the milky way
collided with is
and i'm not joking
the sausage so 10 giga years ago there
was a collision
with this large galaxy greater than 10
billion solar masses so it's a pretty
chonky boy and it was a head-on
collision what this means is that it's a
very messy collision
and so it formed these things called
radial streams so stars basically
they're orbits a straight line more or
less it's highly eccentric and
because of that um
they're pretty hard to discover they
don't form nice patches on the sky
they're more like big mushy clouds in
the sky so they're literally called
hercules aquila cloud and the virgo over
density because they're just
fuzzy patches on the sky that initially
people thought were separate objects
which is why they have different names
but a few years ago my supervisor
noticed that they possibly could be
related
and in my own analysis of the data i
basically noticed that
they keep appearing together why they
always together and so i presented it to
my supervisors saying they have similar
properties
does this mean that they're actually the
same object
and then oh we were thinking this but no
one's gone further than that we just
know that they could be the way the
sausage was
found before was using globular clusters
so little tiny balls of stars orbiting
the milky way and we know that most
galaxies have these goblet clusters and
so when the sausage collided with the
milky way
it deposited its own globular clusters
with the properties of the sausage as in
the same speeds directions stuff like
that and so a phd also here um gucci my
own he noticed that you could probably
look for these globular clusters and
they would be in a certain like bit of
phase space so they would share similar
velocity
properties and this is where we get into
why it's the sausage it's because when
you look at the velocity they're either
burgers so you look like that
meatballs they look like a circle which
is like everything symmetric it's like a
big mess um
or they look like a sausage and so they
noticed all the globular clusters
just formed a slight well a messy line
but not a line nonetheless and so it was
calling the gaia sausage
and so we're just trying to show that
it's not just these goblet clusters now
but it's this physical structure that is
protruding through the milky way
whoa
so i've checked into my room and i've
got a couple of hours to go over my
slides before the talk today isn't it
funny that i have given talks
in so many institutions now
and
this is the one that i think i am most
nervous about
i've taught this is an undergraduate
physics society i've given talks
at other universities are the very
prestigious universities i've even given
a talk at cern and yet
such as the brand power of this
university this is the one that i'm
nervous about something that is
reinforced by
the physical presence here the physical
buildings it's almost like seeing the
system with fresh eyes and reaffirms why
i think it's so important to outreach
for
oxford and cambridge and why i
originally got into making videos which
is for that exact purpose to try and
help kids from state school backgrounds
like me
believe that they can go somewhere like
this it's just
so indeed it's interesting to me that
that effect of feeling like you don't
belong
because of you know imposter syndrome or
background or whatever
it's so strong that it still affects me
even now
and it should this is exactly the same
as any other kind of undergraduate talk
that i've given
i just got to try and not let it
get to me okay so welcome to the lecture
theater at the chemistry department at
cambridge i don't know if you can tell
but it's huge this is um well i said is
this where first-year natural sciences
students have their lectures and i was
told no this is where first-year natural
sciences students have their first
breakdown so um that bodes well so we'll
see how full this gets but um i need to
get set up with my laptop and then i've
just got a cheeky little talk to give
how how can it be
my talk was we need to talk about kelvin
about the development of atmospheric
science why effective science
communication on the topic of climate is
so important and the lessons i've
learned doing it i think it went well
[Applause]
[Laughter]
as i already said the reason i was so
anxious about the talk was the
reputation cambridge has just visiting i
felt pressure to live up to the academic
heritage of the place and i wondered how
sam felt about this did he feel academic
pressure just by being there did he feel
like he was smart enough to belong
and his answer was
very surprising i failed my a levels so
what i didn't fail what um i got
bccc
which it's not fail but it's
it's not you know the three a's you need
to do physics now at university and even
when i did it the average what you
wanted to do was
aab or a starting study like it was
definitely far below failing my a-levels
i got them through clearing if you hear
anyone who went in through clearing you
have to have pity for them because
it generally is probably one of the most
stressful days of my life like still now
like nothing has lived up to loving
physics and wanting to go to uni but
not have like
the chance of it not being there so you
phone up all the universities saying can
you take videos of my grades
um and then eventually
after i gave up was in a cafe having a
penny i couldn't eat because i was so
distraught i phoned at one final
university cause my mum saw an ad on
facebook for them royal holloway yeah
and i was like i don't want to do it but
sure to make my mum be quiet i'll phone
them and
yeah they took me and just throughout
the whole four years i just
tried to get better at physics and maths
and
yeah eventually did my masters um and
here i am so this morning we are going
to have a look around to the colleges
now what was it you said about cambridge
colleges they're like pokemon yes you
have to catch them all
and you haven't visited all of them no
and we are specifically going to be
going to uh st john's and trinity to
have a nosey around and is it fair to
say they're kind of like some of the
most iconic yeah like famous looking
cambridge when you look up cambridge
that is what you see
so this by the way is ray
hello um we met at the talk yesterday
and um a youtuber in your own right we
should point out there'll be a link in
the description if you want to watch
some uh dispatches from the cambridge
front um and you very kindly offered to
show us around yeah no it's my pleasure
where are we at the moment uh so we're
at st john's college uh in first courts
we have
great gates behind us
and then like
the
now in case you can't tell the cable
connecting my fancy external microphone
with wind noise reduction was broken so
unfortunately all the audio from here
was just unusable
but ray incredibly generously showed us
around saint john's which is gorgeous
and even got us access to a place that i
never thought i'd visit
the top of the huge chapel tower
so for viewers at home in case you can't
see this very well we are currently
going up
the towers and charts college chapel
and it is an incredibly tight spiral
staircase
it gets tighter why did i get born with
such broad shoulders
keep this door closed
i don't want to know what's behind that
don't dead open inside
there is a step down
okay
god this is a tiny door
were people not born with shoulders in
the 19th century
holy [ __ ] we were incredibly lucky to be
here
right incredibly kindly let us up this
is uh the most incredible view of
cambridge i know i'm not gonna do this
justice on camera but i'll try
after visiting st john's we were shown
around trinity college by ophelia they
were absolutely wonderful and incredibly
generous with their time but the wind
noise again made all of the clips
unusable the college is gorgeous though
so please enjoy some of the footage
while sam explains how he feels about
studying at cambridge the blessing and
curse of i guess oldsbridge or any good
university anywhere in the world yeah
it's the imposter syndrome thing of
you're here and you're happy and you're
like this is amazing but then you're
also like stephen hawking
walked these grounds and einstein
chatted with eddington down there and
it's like
generally terrifying but i've always had
like this attitude to astronomy in
general is that it's not a terrifying
subject it's a humbling subject to be
able to look at the sky and to
understand the emotions of the heavens
and stars and stuff and i take that same
thing to cambridge in that
because if i don't act humble to be here
then i would feel
immensely like stressed of i need to be
producing 50 papers a day or something
like that but no i've just got to
remember i'm a lonely
second year
just second year phd student and i just
got to keep it in perspective i know
that i'm lucky and i have an opportunity
and i've always been taught like you
know if you have an opportunity
if you've got a privilege to be
somewhere use that privilege for good
and so
it's always in like the back of your
mind you can never like throw it away so
one of the most famous cambridge
traditions
is punting for those of you who don't
know what that is it's basically being
on a flat bottomed boat and you move
yourself around a river by a pole and uh
well when in rome yeah
go hunting
i just wanted to show you struggling oh
thanks mate right so we have acquired a
punt
a great expense
and uh we're currently on the river camp
this is going to be interesting
sam and i both regularly stream on
twitch so we thought we should
livestream us punting otherwise known as
simon and sam on a cam on the cam
here are some
highlights
it's fine it's just some twigs like
apocalypse now
we had a circle bridge because of how
depressed all the students are
they sigh every time they go over
oh god i nearly knocked myself in
that was nearly very very bad and it was
almost on twitch be sure to subscribe
and donate if i do fall in
are you going for speed
oh
so now we're entering trinity
oh my god it's
like dying every time i hear a
stomp oh um um
what what happened it's stuck in the
cell okay do you want to have a go this
is quite a nice broad section of river
ladies and gentlemen it's the
the titular sam on the cam
and me your co-host simon
quite close to the water line let's see
how much closer we can get
okay
what do i do so pull it out of the water
and then basically you want to drop it
in
like that
and basically it's just as simple as
pushing off
so pushing in that's it
and once you push you can use the pole
as like a tiller so you can steer with
it it's going the other way oh god
that's fine i can help i've got a little
awe
yeah
okay so sam's first time punting so be
nice everyone
i kind of want to to be honest
jonah hop on it's all right we've got
these two lovely passengers that we're
going to ferry across like caron this is
also live on the internet which points
out we're streaming this on switch
many
yes
on
watching 60 60 70 60. are you all at
trinity then yeah we're going to go
through enjoy to bring it in a bit more
oh oh now we're going to need to bring
it in
they've done it so you're both so you're
doing a phd so i did a phd and now i do
youtube full time
what's your uh
uh it's just simon clark it's just my
name simon clark it was very nice to
meet you tommy we are part i'll brace
you in the poll
it's got some good grass
thank you very much guys
nice to meet you all right take care
guys
literally i feel like we just did a side
quest there we go kong's college donkey
kong was it wasn't a luminous of kings
this was famously named after martin
luther king oh oh sorry my facts are
wrong yeah let's do a quick little crew
transfer
hold huddle huddle
so
in the
wonderful
look at this sight look at that crane
they also have
this elegance personified
oh no oh no
what do you mean i know
don't say things like that
oh god i just splash myself no you have
to work too
everyone's gonna paddle our way to
victory
sorry for interrupting your date
every i think every phd you have to do
like a viva at the end of your first
year to make sure you're doing work
you're not just saving all the money one
of the questions is what are you going
to do and
it is hard i
i know that i would like to stay in
academia and do some form of teaching
um what i want the phd itself to be i
have the ob not the obligation i would
like it to be beneficial to something
like i would like someone to maybe not
read my thesis but at least some of the
papers that i've done and even if it
inspires like one person or something
like that i don't know or it helps find
something like to do with dark matter or
something that just has an effect on
like human society in science it might
not solve something
like that saves people lives but i just
value so much like the artistic sides of
stuff of someone like looking up and
seeing like nebulae and stuff like that
so if like my phd could do something
that inspires someone
then that would be the thing i would
care most about
if you've been inspired by sam's
research and would like to learn more
about how he goes about it talking about
programming his day-to-day work and his
love of statistical modelling then check
out his extended interview on nebula
you've probably heard of nebula by now
it's the streaming service co-owned and
operated by a huge number of educational
youtubers including me it's like youtube
but has no ads whatsoever and a
chronological timeline as well as
extended versions of videos available on
youtube available earlier on nebula
there's a raft of slick original
productions such as better elevation
about how we make videos and story mode
about storytelling in video games nebula
is a subscription service meaning that
instead of constantly seeing ads like on
youtube you pay for access and that fee
is distributed between the creators so
by signing up you directly support
educational video but that's not all you
don't just get access to the bit of
youtube you already watch but with no
ads and support people like me you also
get access to our partners curiosity
stream curiosity stream is the number
one source of high quality documentaries
on the web here you can watch for
example jim alcale's amazing gravity
continuing the discussion from this
video or if you prefer something more
tangible secret life underground about
the fascinating complexity going on
underneath our feet with thousands of
titles and amazing presenters from
hannah fry to hans rosling it's like
netflix but will make you smarter you
can sign up to get access to both nebula
and curiositystream at
curiositystream.com simon clark and
doing so you get 26 off a subscription
in fact if you're watching this before
the 29th of november you get an
adams-tastic 42 off a subscription
meaning you get access to premium
documentaries indie content and support
educational video for less than a dollar
a month that's curiositystream.com
simon clark with thanks to
curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video
thank you so much for watching the video
i really hope that you enjoyed it this
series is very close to my heart and i
had a great time in cambridge and i hope
that came across in the video if you did
like it then please do pop it a like and
check out the previous videos in the
series up here also check out sam on
twitch he regularly streams and does
study streams of what he's up to in his
research which is linked down in the
description that just leaves me to say
thank you again for watching and i'll
see you in the next one